I ran to get here but we're between a
rock and a hard place
it's really a mess officials have set a
deadline of March 31st for a framework
agreement to control Iran's nuclear
ambitions
however after intense negotiations
obstacle remains on uranium enrichment
where stockpiles and richer radium
should be stored limits on Iran's
nuclear research and development and the
timing and scope of sanction relief
among other issues according to the
Associated Press all right so basically
it sounds like we're shelving this thing
until June because I know we all really
want to hear more about the Iran deal
and the secret negotiations sounds like
it's gonna be a framework agreement not
a final agreement it's all about words
and trickery I read a lot I'm on Twitter
and all that stuff I don't know who to
trust with this thing at all so first of
June does that do you think that makes
any difference really pushing this thing
they've been talking about this for
years do you think adding three months
is gonna help us get there I guess the
real question is what is the
intelligence that we have that says that
they are closer than ever to actually
producing a nuclear weapon because it
sounds like the Obama administration
thinks that the restrictions that are
going to be in place that kicking this
thing down the line is actually going to
extend the amount of time that it would
take for Iran to produce something right
but as you said this we've been talking
about this for years why is it all of a
sudden Iran's like oh we should make
nukes a great idea so isn't this all
about who you trust like everyone keeps
a business does the u.s. trust Iran does
around but it's like I don't even trust
our media to report it properly so how
do how do we like normal people how are
we supposed to decide who do you trust
when it comes to listening to this stuff
I mean you I don't think you can really
trust anybody anymore like they've been
saying Iran's close to making a bomb for
the last 25 years it's like what are
they doing some like tantrik bomb
they're so close it's like eventually
like when's it gonna explode like when's
he gonna happen but yeah I get this
point how do you even take it seriously
like to me it seems like trying to get a
development deal in Hollywood just like
you keep getting the details it's like
well they want to develop this script
like now we say well let's do this take
three months and like decide what we
were to do
like well wait a year and just like they
take your development deal away and
you're like I [ __ ] the hater on the
easiest correlation for me you have to
make things I feel their pain it's like
you just want to get this script made
they're like but but but yeah so as part
of it that that they've literally
everyone's been talking about this for
so long like that's why this seems so
ridiculous to me because literally
people were talking about this in
Congress in the 80s and we're still
talking about it I don't know that it's
any scarier now maybe it is scarier I
think for me part of the real situation
here is that like who are we to tell
another nation and granted I don't want
Iran to every I don't think that's a
good idea so there's a philosophical
part in like a real part yes who who is
America to tell other nations that they
are not allowed to enrich uranium they
are not allowed to stockpile these
weapons when we are the world leader in
nuclear weapons and we're not willing to
even meet anybody halfway I mean I
remember watching countdown to zero that
amazing documentary about disarmament
like five years ago
and just crying because I was just so
depressed by the fact that we are not
setting a good example here and the
truth of the matter is it's easy when we
live in America and we sit on this
cookie cushy couch to go oh we would
never make a mistake yeah [ __ ] crazy
right so do you see that distinction
there's like a philosophical thing where
it's like well who were we to tell
anyone but at the same time I don't
think any of us want Iran to have a bomb
right no I feel like we've become like
America is the author of the rest of the
world's parent and there are kids off to
college I'm like hey if you want my
money this is what you're gonna do yeah
I'm gonna date that guy you're not gonna
go to that party and I'm gonna keep
paying your tuition so I was like if you
want to make a bomb fine but you won't
get any money for us and you're by the
way that's exactly what my parents say
to me when I went to college they were
like if you which is smart of them yeah
if we are the parents of the rest of the
world we're like the crack addict oh
yeah we're the worst parents like we're
the do it do as I say not as I do
right like that's something we have to
remember is as much as we're like Iran
should not have a bomb think about all
the Iranian so we're probably good right
but we have the bomb because we know
what to do with it we're gonna keep them
safe but you can't have a bomb because
we don't trust you and by the way we're
not only the only ones that have used
them but we use them more than once and
not just that we are also like
excessively using drone strikes we're I
mean they're resource and America and
force like go together like peanut
butter and jelly if we start talking
drone strikes right now this thing will
never end anyway hahahaha nukes should
Iran happen to have any right to tell
them not to what should the world do and
who do you trust let us know in the
comments right now